I hope not
um but you never know it's
um
yes why the the athletes need to make
the most of it whilst they're they're
still able to because you know if they
were if I was to have another big injury
or something happened with the
you know the metal hit that would that
would be me finished and I wouldn't try
to come back from another operation or a
major surgery again so
um you know I want to keep playing a bit
longer
um
you know I know it's not going to be
going on forever but I have an idea of
when I would you know I would like to
finish
um and it's not the issues Wimbledon can
you tell us when it is
no because because I I don't know
exactly which tournament it would be you
know I want to finish on my own terms I
want to finish on the court whilst I
still feel I can do my self-justice and
I'm playing at a really high level and
um you know I definitely feel I can do
that for a couple more years my family
have been incredibly supported my wife's
been amazing and you know pushing me to
you know keep
um you know keep going and keep working
hard and
um I think that's for the right reasons
I hope it's not because she just once
wants to get me out the house but it is
a stressful lifestyle isn't it and um
Nick curios has admitted that he had
Suicidal Thoughts when he lost a match
to Rafa in 2019 we does that surprise
you
um
probably not I don't mean in like Nick's
case they're just meaning like
individual sports are are difficult like
you're putting yourself out there
you know every single week
um and
granted I'm fully aware there is way
more important things in life than a
tennis match and I'm sure Nick as well
is also very aware of that but
you know sometimes it is very difficult
like when you're on on the tour it can
become quite a lonely place and you know
when you're sitting in hotel rooms on
your own and you've had tough losses and
are away from your friends and family
and those sorts of things like yeah you
can have some some really tough moments
and it doesn't surprise me when
you know athletes struggle with with
their their mental health there's the
whole you know social media deal side of
things that you know probably 15 20
years ago wasn't really an issue but you
know that's also not easy you know you
get back to your room
look at Twitter or Instagram and you get
receiving tons of abuse when you're
already probably not in a great place
and it's it's not not easy
um Novak Djokovic meanwhile continuing
to amass titles and seems very keen to
get as many in the bag as possible and
doesn't really look like he's letting up
do you think he's now the greatest of
all time and if he isn't considered to
be so now will be
um yeah I mean look there's he
definitely there's arguments there for
him to be the the greatest of of all
time
um
you know the thing that for me has been
really special about those three guys is
that on you know their their their
surfaces
um you know that's rap on the clay I
mean I don't think anyone can doubt he's
the best clay Court player of all time
from me Novak is clearly the best
hardcore player of all time and then
grass is kind of
still still to be still to be decided um
between probably him and him and Roger
and
um but yeah what all those guys have
achieved is is amazing
um you know if you just go on Grand Slam
titles then you know you would have to
have to give that to Novak but for me
it's a slightly more nuanced than that
and finally
um it's been a really big talking point
in tennis for over 12 months now about
the Russian Bella Russian players not
being allowed to play at Wimbledon last
year they are playing this year do you
have any thoughts on that is that the
right thing to do and if you had to play
a player for one of those countries
would it affect you in any way
well I mean I I have competed against
players from those countries and I you
know I wouldn't say that has has
affected me I mean you know I've the
utmost sympathy for all of the Ukrainian
players that are playing and are put in
that that situation I can only imagine
how difficult that must be
um
you know for them to to deal with
and also the tournaments are you know
they're also in in a really they've been
put in a really difficult situation as
well with the governing bodies some of
these events like with the the sanctions
that were getting placed on them you
know potentially wouldn't have been able
to survive like another year
um as well without ranking points and
the fines and stuff that we're getting
you know placed against them if they
didn't allow the the Russians and Bella
Russians to play so
you know it was also really
difficult one I think for for the
tournaments as well